I want to begin by thanking all of the
incredible medical professionals the
doctors the nurses everybody at Walter
Reed Medical Center I think it's the
finest in the world for the incredible
job they've been doing uh I came here
wasn't feeling so well I feel much
better now we're working hard to get me
all the way back I have to be back
because we still have to make America
great again we've done an awfully good
job of that but we still have steps to
go and we have to finish that job and
I'll be back I think I'll be back soon
and I look forward to finishing up the
campaign the way it was started and the
way we've been doing and the kind of
numbers that we've been doing we've been
so proud of it but this was something
that happened and it's happened to
millions of people all over the world
and I'm fighting for them not just in
the US I'm fighting for them all over
the world we're going to beat this
Corona virus or whatever you want to
call it and we're going to Beat It
soundly so many things have happened if
you look at the Therapeutics which I'm
taking right now some of them and others
are coming out soon that are looking
like uh frankly they're Miracles if you
want to know the truth they're Miracles
people criticize me when I say that but
we have things happening that look like
they're Miracles coming down from God so
I just want to tell you that I'm
starting to feel good uh you don't know
over the next period of a few few days I
guess that's the real test so we'll be
seeing what happens over those next next
couple of days I just want to be so
thankful for all of the support I've
seen whether it's on television or
reading about it uh I most of all
appreciate what's been said by the
American people by almost a bipartisan
consensus of American people it's
beautiful thing to see and I very much
appreciate it and I won't forget it I
promise you that I also want to thank
the leaders of the world
for uh their condolences and they're
they know what we're going through they
know what as your leader what I have to
go through but I had no choice because I
just didn't want to stay in the white
house I was given that alternative stay
in the white house lock yourself in
don't ever leave don't even go to the
Oval Office just stay upstairs and enjoy
it don't see people don't talk to people
and just be done with it and I can't do
that I had to be out front and this is
America this is the United States this
is the greatest country in the world
this is the most powerful country in the
world I can't be locked up in a room
upstairs and totally safe and uh just
say hey whatever happens happens I can't
do that we have to confront problems as
a leader you have to confront problems
there's never been a great leader that
would have done that so that's where it
is I'm doing well I want to thank
everybody our first lady is doing very
well Melania asked me to say something
as to the respect that she has for our
country the love that she has for our
country and uh we're both doing well
Melania is uh really handling it very
nicely as you've probably read she's
slightly younger than me just a little
tiny bit and uh therefore just we know
the disease we know the situ ation with
age versus uh younger people and Milani
is handling it statistically like it's
supposed to be handled and that makes me
very happy and it makes the country very
happy but I'm also doing well and I
think we're going to have a very good
result again over the next few days
we're going to probably know for sure so
I just want to thank everybody out there
everybody all over the world
specifically the United States the
outpouring of love has been incredible I
will never forget thank you very much